[Música]
uma boa tarde a todos
a nossa conversa de hoje é sobre uma das
mais importantes capacidades humanas
a capacidade da decisão numa era com
tantas opções como decidir como fazer a
escolha certa diante das decisões mais
importantes das nossas vidas
aquelas que vão definir em grande parte
como será o nosso futuro se teremos
êxito ou não se seremos felizes ou não
uma das melhores formas de se abordar a
personalidade humana é compreendê la
como uma estrutura narrativa isso mesmo
eu e você estamos escrevendo as nossas
biografias a medida em que vivemos cada
dia devido uma página escrita algumas
decisões são feitas de modo muito
natural
isso por conta das nossas convicções
detalhes convicções essas que refletem
valores inegociáveis por exemplo pra mim
é um valor inegociável sempre foi a
família desde que eu me entendo por
gente eu sonhava em me casar e formar a
minha própria família
mas é claro que pra isso eu precisava de
recursos
eu precisava de ter um ofício de
desenvolver uma capacidade
foi aí que eu prestei vestibular para
medicina
fui aprovado e logo nos primeiros
períodos já escutava a seguinte pergunta
o que é isso a aula já sabem que você
vai especializar
pra falar a verdade eu não falar eu não
fazia a menor idéia
meu pai não é médico minha mãe não é
médica
eu literalmente poderia escolher
qualquer especialidade mas como escolher
e uma vez tendo escolhido como saber que
aquela foi a resposta certa é bom mas eu
pensei 'você tem 56 anos pra escolher e
decidir qual especialidade no início da
faculdade
o interessante é que são os professores
que atendem os pacientes e os alunos
observam e como é bonito observar alguém
que domine a uma técnica alguém que
cumpre bem o seu papel
eu observava aquele professor e ficava
impressionado como que ele dominava tudo
na especialidade dele e ainda resolver
problemas de outras áreas
aquilo era muito impressionante mas aí
um dia eu percebi que havia uma única
exceção é quando os pacientes
apresentavam sintomas psiquiátricos como
depressão ansiedade mesmo a psicose
aquele exímio professor
de repente se mostrava desconcertado
havia ali algo fora dos seus domínios
eu vi aquilo e pensava com seria
interessante se eu fosse capaz de
dominar essa área específica
pela primeira vez a realidade me
convocava psiquiatria
agora todas as vezes que mencionava o
interesse e me tornar um psiquiatra
obtinha mesma reação tem certeza se quer
a tria você sabe que o dia a dia é
pesado né
você sabe o tipo de paciente você vai
ter que atender
e para falar a verdade eu não tinha
consistência biográfica nenhuma e acabei
dando ouvidos
pensei vou deixar pra lá vou escolher
uma especialidade comum mesmo porque bom
é conforto e qualidade de vida muito bem
os períodos se passaram e eu tentava de
todas as formas me interessar por outras
especialidades mas sem nenhum sucesso
e pior ainda quando dei por mim lá se
foram seis anos na faculdade e é chegado
o grande momento da decisão e que
palavra interessante né decisão
a decisão significa corte a decisão
significa cortar fora eu corto lanço
fora as opções que eu não quero
e sobretudo tomo pra mim a parte que me
cabe é bonito isso né
mas eu não estava pronto para escolher a
especialidade não eu estava pronta para
me casar mas pra isso eu precisava de um
emprego
foi então trabalhar como clínico-geral
uma cidadezinha de 8 mil habitantes
para ser mais preciso na zona rural de
e lá eu atendia muitos pacientes não
todos os dias com os mais diversos
problemas de saúde o atendimento
transcorria no seu ritmo normal com uma
única exceção é quando o paciente
apresentava os sintomas psiquiátricos
casos como depressão ansiedade e psicose
quando isso acontecia eu queria saber
mais
entender mais sobre o que se passava com
aquela pessoa
sabe quanto sua atenção converge quase
que totalmente por um único ponto
é aí que o instante ganha peso de
eternidade
é aí que eu sei que o que eu faço é
exatamente o que eu deveria estar
fazendo
preste muita atenção com que é capaz de
fazer isso com você
é a realidade convocando então dentre
todos os pacientes que atende a esses
eram aqueles que chamavam mais a minha
atenção
esses eram aqueles aos quais eu me
inclino nava quase que naturalmente mais
uma vez era realidade me chamando
é que a trilha é como se ela dissesse
essa é a parte que cabe e aí você vai
fazer o quê com isso e para escutar o
chamado da realidade é necessário
utilizar a nossa consciência
o psiquiatra austríaco victor franco
criador da logoterapia dizia que a
consciência é um aparelho captador de
sentido e que o ser humano tem sede de
sentido
e veja bem não sou eu quem criou o
sentido ele já está lá não em mim na
minha cabeça
nos meus esquemas mentais mas na
realidade da vida na concretude dos
atendimentos numa zona rural
eu escutei a realidade me convocando e
dessa vez me apresentei
afinal de contas se não eu quem
eu decidi pela psiquiatria
mas o conforto ea qualidade de vida
existe uma frase que diz quem tem um
porquê viver pode suportar quase
qualquer como mais uma vez quem tem um
qualquer como essa frase que admite era
muito utilizada por frank e eu
acrescentaria quem não tenham porque
viver não estará satisfeito nem na
abundância e nem no conforto
o filósofo espanhol o tag gás e dizia
que o ser humano faz tudo por motivos
líricos
ou seja nós estamos em busca de uma
certa poesia na vida em busca de sentido
e o oposto do lirismo é o prosar a smo o
cotidiano mecânico que nada mais é que
uma simples seqüência de acontecimentos
sem sentido
a nossa grande poetisa mineira adélia
prado
certa vez escreveu de vez em quando deus
me tira a poesia
eu olho pedra e vejo pedra
mesmo quando eu não procuro sentido pra
tomar as minhas decisões
quando eu escolho outro caminho que não
aquele para o qual a realidade me
convoca eu traio a minha própria
história
eu nego a minha própria narrativa
pessoal eu passo a ser mais genérico e
menos pessoal eu passo a ser menos eu
e é por isso que quando a realidade
convocar tenhamos todos uma coisa em
mente
senão eu tem obrigado